sex can feel pretty great but have you
ever stops in the middle of it to wonder
why what actually happens to your brain
in body during sex there are a lot of
different types of sex but for all the
first step is usually arousal increased
blood flow causes tissues like your
chest to swell and your face to get
what's known as sex flush for those with
a penis blood flowing gorges the three
spongy areas along the length of the
shaft creating an erection for those
with vagina the opening inner and outer
labia swell as well this increased
pressure causes fluid production from
both the Barthel and gland and skinny's
gland which helped to create lubrication
in a woman neurotransmitters are
released to help relax the muscle in the
wall and make the vagina both longer and
wider
there's a white held belief that women
require more time to achieve arousal but
using thermographic cameras on people's
genitals while they watched porn
researchers found that it took healthy
men and women both 30 seconds to begin
arousal and reaching maximum arousal
around 10 minutes in researchers have
actually documented penetrative vaginal
intercourse by getting eight couples to
perform missionary sex in an MRI tube
this study revealed that during
intercourse two-thirds of the erect
penis is pendulous and moved upwards at
an angle of about 120 degrees from the
root of the penis meanwhile the uterus
raises up by two point four centimeters
and changes the configuration of the
woman's bladder a woman's breasts may
increase in size by up to 25 percent and
men's testicles can grow by 50% while
rising closer to the body though all of
the men orgasms in this experiment and
none of the women did which isn't
uncommon a survey of over 1,400 women
found that only 21 to 30 percent of
women experienced an orgasm during
intercourse that was not assisted by
extra digital or oral stimulation oral
sex on women can provide direct
stimulation to the clitoris the clitoris
is actually much bigger than it appears
and is about four inches long with about
three-quarters of the structure being
internal the clitoris and penis are
similar they both have glands a foreskin
also known as the hood erectile tissue
and a shaft but unlike the penis the
only known function of the clit is
pleasure
there's also anal sex which is the
insertion of a penis or a dildo into a
partner's rectum though it's the primary
Orma sex among gay men its popularity
has surged among straight couples a 2008
survey found that 44% of straight men
and 36% of straight women have had anal
sex your anus and surrounding area have
a lot of nerve endings including the
pudendal nerve which controls muscles in
your external anal sphincter and carries
sensations to the anus penis and
clitoris and then penetration can
stimulate the glandular organ known as
the prostate though there's no published
laboratory research anecdotal evidence
suggests that prostate orgasms are more
powerful and pleasurable than penile
induced ones for women anal penetration
can stimulate the perennial sponge which
sits between the vaginal opening and
rectum so pressure can result in
pleasure and orgasm characterized by
contractions of the genitals in the end
you have the orgasm when it comes to the
brain the experience is pretty similar
for men and women and men dopamine
synthesizing neurons are activated
during ejaculation and in women the
reward center that releases dopamine is
activated too for both areas in the
cerebellum become activated while
significant parts of your cortex
completely shut down at the same time
oxytocin the hormone responsible for
bonding is released from the pituitary
gland making you more likely to cuddle
up after sex so yes like all good things
sex is very scientific and yet this
video is probably demonetized because we
mentioned sex and even in a completely
educational context it's deemed
inappropriate and flagged so we wanted
to talk about this in our new podcast
alongside other science questions like
whether sex ed actually increases sexual
activity why condoms expire and also
tell funny stories from the awkward sex
talks with our parents growing up you
can listen to it by searching for side
note on iTunes or using the link that we
put in our description we're honestly so
excited by our new podcast and have
loved every second of making it and the
support from you our YouTube audience
would mean the world thanks for watching
and we'll see you over at the podcast